ابداوا في التطورات في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا مع اقتراب اكمالها شهرها العاشر
حيث اعلن الجيش الاوكراني حاله تاهب الجوي
في عموم البلاد محذرا من موجه هجمات روسيه
جديده وقالت هيتلر كان الاوكراني ان قوه
صدات هجوما روسيا على اكثر من 20 بلده في
مقاطعه دنيا اسك ولا نحو 25 قريه اخرى في
محيط مدينه بخمول تعرضت لقصف روسيا كثيف
وفي احداث ميدانيه اخرى قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيا القوات الروسيه تستهدفه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بنحو 163 صاروخا خلال
الساعه الماضيه الذي فعلتها الجويه اسقطت
كثيرا منها كما قالت قياده عمليات الجنوب
ان القذف الروسيه استمر على مرافق البنيه
التحتيه في مقاطع
عن سقوط ضحايا وقطاعات في امدادات
الكهرباء
اسقطت صاروخين روسيين اطلقا من شبه جزيره
القرن باتجاه مناطق في المقاطعه
فدى مراسل الجزيره من القصه المدفعيه
المتبادل بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
ما زال مستمرا على طول نهر
الخير سون قالت سلطات سالم روسيا انها
بدات بانشائي قبه فوق مرفقي تخزين
النفايات النوويه المستنده في محطه ذا ابو
راشيا النوويه بهدف حمايتها من هجمات
الطائرات المسيره الاوكرانيه على حد قولها